hey guys get straight out here earlier
this month I celebrated my mother's
birthday by paying her a surprise visit
to the town where she works in we live
in separate towns and throughout the
five six years of not being in the
country
I've always sent gifts cakes and cuts
from abroad and so I thought I would do
something different this year instead of
just buying her another cake I decided
to bake my first ever carrot cake and
surprise her her shocked reaction and
pure joy reminded me one of the main
reasons why I decided to come back which
is to be closer to my family and friends
I have to be honest I was really nervous
that the cake would be a disaster but it
turns out to be super yummy and
everybody loved it and of course this
carrot cake was a healthier version with
no butter no artificial sugar it is low
in calories and low in fat
most carrot cake so that I've tried tend
to be overly sweet and it is very high
in calories this carrot cake however is
very moist naturally sweetened crunchy
and it is actually good for you
so my mom and a friend could enjoy the
cable without feeling guilty and so I
posted our special moment on Facebook
and Instagram you guys requested for the
recipe
here it is
next Sunday is Mother's Day so bake this
cake for your mother and surprise her or
they give really loved ones a cake made
by you with love will always taste
yummier compared to store-bought cakes
so let's start with the cake the
ingredients you need are 1 cup of whole
wheat or white flour or a mixture of
both I use half and half 2.5 teaspoons
of baking powder 1 teaspoon of cinnamon
all mixed spices 2 X 4 taken you may
want meat this 1/2 a cup of honey or
maple syrup cut a cup of extra virgin
olive oil 1/2 a cup of applesauce
unsweetened one teaspoon of vanilla
extract one and a half cups of carrots
peeled and grated and 1/2 a cup of
ground cashew nuts
preheat the oven to 180 degrees Celsius
or 350 degrees Fahrenheit in a bowl
combine the dry ingredients flour baking
powder and mix spices set aside in a
large bowl beat the eggs on high speed
for about 1 minute until foamy add in
the honey and beat on high speed for
another 3 to 4 minutes until well
combined then stir in the olive oil
apple sauce and vanilla extract until
thoroughly combined next add in half of
the flour mixture and stir it until just
combined then add in the remaining flour
mixture stir well finally fill in the
grated carrots and cashew nuts
Greece is a heart-shaped team or an
inch-thick team with a little bit of
olive oil pour the batter into the cake
team and spread out evenly place into
the oven and bake for 30 to 35 minutes
until a toothpick inserted into the
center comes out clean while waiting for
the cake to bake in the oven let's go
ahead and make the light and healthy
cream-cheese frosting
only three main ingredients three ounces
of cream cheese quarter cup of plain
yogurt and half a teaspoon of vanilla
extract you can also add 2 tablespoons
of stevia for extra sweetness this is
optional in a pan or ball B the cream
cheese and too soft for about one minute
add in the yogurt and vanilla extract
continue to be for two to three minutes
and to smooth and well combined finally
stir in the stevia children cream cheese
frosting in the fridge until ready to
use once the cake is done remove from
the oven and allow it to cool completely
to room temperature before assembling
and frosting your cake if your cake is
still warm your frosting will melt so
cover the entire cake generously with
frosting this step can be tedious so
really take your time and just enjoy the
process and because we're using yogurt
this light and healthy frosting will be
thinner than your typical butter and
sugar load of frosting don't worry about
it
the frosting will thicken once chilled
once the entire cake is covered with
frosting it is time to decorate the cake
how you like it
my mom loves the crunchy texture of nuts
especially cashew nuts
so I'll top my cake with 1/3 cup of
ground cashew nut
and decorate with sliced strawberries
around the heart topped with few
blueberries presenting cake how you know
your mum or your loved ones would like
it so try different toppings
this cake is best eaten on the same day
but chill in the fridge it is not in
turn right away it will last three to
four days in the fridge
this skinny and healthy carrot cake is
very moist with other crunchiness for
the nuts
it is sweetened with natural goodness
from the honey and apple sauce and you
can actually taste and bite into the
carrots one serving of cake with a cream
cheese frosting only has about 200
calories which is less than the
traditional singulair recipe which has
about 300 calories and because these are
all natural ingredients which are good
for you
you and your loved ones can enjoy the
cake without feeling guilty so be sure
to try my skinny healthy carrot cake
recipe and bake it for your loved ones
you can even turn this into Chum mini
cup muffins and have them for breakfast
or snacks
try it and share your creation with me
on Facebook and Instagram all the best
for new Fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my You Tube channel and website do
you follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you
you